welcome to the world of soilless
gardening today we're diving into the
exciting realm of Hydroponics and
aquaponics these Innovative techniques
are revolutionizing agriculture by
offering sustainable and efficient ways
to grow food this essay will be your
guide to understanding these two
fascinating methods we'll explore their
inner workings compare their strengths
and weaknesses and equip you to choose
the perfect system for your needs buckle
up and let's embark on this journey
together
imagine a garden where plants Thrive
without ever touching soil that's the
magic of hydroponics in this method
plants are grown in nutrient-rich Water
Solutions their roots are supported by
inert mediums like Coco koir perlite or
clay Pebbles these mediums provide
stability and ation Hydroponics offers
precise control over nutrients leading
to faster growth and higher yields it's
ideal for leafy greens herbs and even
fruits like tomatoes and strawberries
aquaponics takes Hydroponics a step
further by incorporating fish into the
equation this Innovative system combines
aquaculture which is the raising of fish
with Hydroponics the cultivation of
plants in Water by merging these two
practices aquaponics creates a
sustainable and efficient method of food
production it's a closed loop system
where fish waste provides natural
fertilizer for plants the fish produce
waste that is high in ammonia which can
be harmful to them if it accumulates
however in an aquaponic system this
waste is a valuable resource here's how
it works fish are raised in tanks and
their waste water is pumped to the plant
beds the water now rich in nutrients
flows through the plant roots providing
them with essential minerals and
compounds needed for growth beneficial
bacteria break down the waste into
nutrients that plants readily absorb
these bacteria convert the ammonia from
the fish waste into nitrites and then
into nitrates which are a form of
nitrogen that plants can easily take up
in return the plants purify the water
which is then res circulated back to the
fish tank the plant roots act as a
natural filter removing toxins and
excess nutrients from the water ensuring
a clean and healthy environment for the
fish this creates a harmonious cycle
that mimics Nature's efficiency by
working together the fish and plants
create a balanced ecosystem that
requires minimal external inputs this
method not only conserves water but also
produces both fish and plants making it
a highly productive and sustainable
farming
[Music]
system the most significant difference
between Hydroponics and aquaponics lies
in their nutrient sources Hydroponics
relies on commercially prepared mineral
nutrients while aquaponics utilizes fish
waste this fundamental distinction
affects their complexity and cost
Hydroponics tends to be simpler to set
up and operate making it more beginner
friendly aquaponics with its added
element of fish care requires a deeper
understanding of biological
processes section five Hydroponics
advantages and disad advantages
Hydroponics offers numerous advantages
including faster plant growth higher
yields and reduced water usage compared
to traditional soil-based gardening it
also eliminates the need for weeding and
reduces the risk of soil born diseases
however Hydroponics requires a financial
investment in equipment and nutrients it
also demands careful monitoring of
nutrient levels and pH balance to ensure
optimal plant
health section six aquaponic benefits
and challenges aquaponics shines in its
ability to produce both fish and
vegetables in a single integrated system
this reduces waste and promotes
sustainability it also eliminates the
need for synthetic fertilizers and
minimizes water usage however aquaponics
can be more challenging to manage
requiring expertise in both fish care
and plant cultivation balancing the
needs of both organisms is crucial for a
successful
system section seven cost comparison
from small gardens to large- scale Farms
the cost of setting up a hydroponic or
aquaponic system varies depending on the
scale and complexity of the operation
whether you're a hobbyist looking to
grow fresh herbs in your kitchen or a
commercial farmer aiming to produce
large quantities of vegetables the
initial investment can vary
significantly smallscale home setups can
range from a few hundred to a couple of
thousand while large scale commercial
systems can cost tens of thousands or
even more for those just starting out a
small hydroponic garden can be an
excellent way to dip your toes into the
world of soilless farming without
breaking the bank small scale setups for
home gardens these systems are perfect
for urban dwellers or anyone with
limited space they allow you to grow a
variety of plants from leafy greens to
small fruits right in your home basic
hydroponic system $200 to $500 these
kits often include everything you need
to get started such as grow lights
nutrient Solutions and a simple setup
for your plants basic aquaponic system
$500 to
$1,500 these systems combine fish
farming with plant cultivation creating
a symbiotic environment where fish waste
provides nutrients for the plants large-
scale setups for commercial farms for
those looking to scale up commercial
systems offer the ability to produce
large quantities of food efficiently
these setups are often found in green
houses or dedicated farming
facilities commercial hydroponic system
10,000 to $100,000 or more these systems
are highly Advanced featuring automated
nutrient delivery climate control and
extensive monitoring to ensure optimal
plant growth commercial aquaponic system
$20,000 to $200,000 or more
these setups are complex and require
significant investment but offer the
benefit of producing both fish and
plants making them a versatile option
for commercial
farming both Hydroponic and aquaponic
systems require regular maintenance to
ensure Optimal Performance this
maintenance is crucial for the health
and productivity of your plants and fish
daily tasks for both systems include
checking water levels which is essential
to prevent dehydration or oversaturation
of your plants and to maintain a stable
environment for your fish fish
monitoring nutrient solutions for
Hydroponics is vital to ensure that
plants receive the right balance of
nutrients for aquaponics keeping an eye
on fish health is equally important as
healthy fish contribute to a balanced
ecosystem inspecting plants for pests or
diseases should be a routine part of
your maintenance schedule early
detection can prevent infestations and
diseases from spreading ensuring the
longevity and productivity of your
system weekly tasks involve adjusting pH
levels to maintain the optimal range for
plant growth adding nutrients to
hydroponic systems is necessary to
replenish what plants have absorbed
cleaning filters and aquaponic systems
helps to keep the water clean and free
of debris when it comes to time
commitment it's important to plan your
schedule accordingly for Hydroponics you
can expect to spend about 1 to 2 hours
per week for a small system this time
includes daily checks and weekly
maintenance tasks larger setups will
naturally require more time and effort
potentially several hours per week
depending on the complexity and scale of
your system for aquaponics plan on
dedicating around 2 to 3 hours per week
for a small system this includes feeding
the fish checking water quality and
Performing routine maintenance larger
aquaponic systems will require more time
often several hours per week to ensure
everything runs smoothly regular
maintenance and monitoring are key to a
successful and productive
system the profitability of Hydroponics
and aquaponics depends on various
factors including crop selection market
demand operational efficiency and
initial investment costs Hydroponics
generally offers faster crop cycles and
higher yields potentially leading to
quicker returns aquaponics while
requiring a longer time to establish can
generate income from both fish and
vegetable sales diversifying revenue
[Music]
streams section 10 common problems in
Solutions Hydroponics nutrient
imbalances regularly test and adjust
nutrient Solutions algae growth block
light from reaching the nutrient
solution root rot ensure proper aeration
and drainage aquaponics fish diseases
quarantine fish and maintain good water
quality nutrient deficiencies monitor
fish waste and supplement if needed pH
fluctuations use buffering agents and
monitor
regularly section 11 success stories
inspiration from Real World Growers
hydroponic success loofah farms in
Montreal Canada operates rooftop green
houses using Hydroponics to provide
fresh local produce to Urban residents
year round aquaponic success the urban
farming guys in Kansas City Missouri run
a successful aquaponic Farm supplying
fresh produce and fish to local
restaurants and farmers
markets section 12 choosing the right
system factors to consider when choosing
between Hydroponics and aquaponics
consider your space budget time
commitment and personal preferences
choose Hydroponics if you want a simpler
system to manage you prioritize faster
crop cycles and higher yields you have
limited space choose aquaponics if
you're passionate about sustainability
and Clos Loop systems you want to raise
both fish and vegetables you're
comfortable with the added complexity of
fish
care section 13 conclusion embracing the
future of farming Hydroponics and
aquaponics offer exciting possibilities
for the future of food production by
embracing these Innovative techniques we
can grow more food with fewer resources
reduce our environmental impact and
create a more sustainable and resilient
food system whether you're a seasoned
Gardener or a curious beginner we
encourage you to explore the world of
soilless gardening and discover the joys
of growing your own food in harmony with
nature